so your deal in April cerberus coming
out what does that tell you that the
smart money is doing right now in the
real estate market yeah in the
single-family market it's absolutely a
trend of consolidation you have a
handful maybe half a dozen or more
players that are getting bigger that are
buying the smaller companies because
we've got institutional platforms we've
got lower cost of capital access to the
credit markets and so you're seeing a
lot of the smaller players ultimately
sell for a variety of reasons and I
think it makes sense for the bigger
players to continue to grow at the heart
of this though is also about demand and
we've seen demand for rentals just go
off the charts and it's you have cheap
homes it's really hard to get a mortgage
and people just don't make enough money
Bloomberg News kind of crunched the
numbers and look at the affordability
gap of what it meant for Millennials to
buy a home in places like New York or
San Francisco and it's $6,500 in New
York way more if you count things like
Brooklyn and Queens in the Bronx and
it's $60,000 in San Francisco $80,000 in
San Jose what does that chart look like
to you in the next five years in terms
of buying there's absolutely absolutely
a gap in certain markets I think New
York and San Francisco highlight really
different trends in the markets were
owning homes in in the southwest and
southeast Florida Atlanta Dallas Phoenix
the affordability is actually there if
you look at that same study it's
actually quite affordable to buy a home
boy the reason you're seeing such strong
rental demand is because not everyone
get a mortgage so even though the
affordability is there to buy a home
it's a great decision
we're buying homes a lot of people can't
do that and so from a rental perspective
you're still able to get great value a
terrific home without all the hassle of
owning it and that's what silver Bay
does we buy high quality homes and good
neighborhoods that people want to buy
and maybe they'll buy in a few years but
rental option now is a viable one
doesn't ask what's there the average age
in your areas of people who buy our
average age were young families they're
in their 30s historically they were
first-time homebuyers but now what we're
seeing is they're taking a few years to
rent a home some by choice and others
because they need to build a credit back
up and so it's really great for our
industry because it's a new second
and millions of people that are gonna
rent homes for one two maybe five years
but then they'll buy a home in the
future what does this tell you about the
US economy and sort of where we are in a
recovery cycle in the housing market so
I think it tells us a couple of things
first there are some demographic shifts
there's some lifestyle shifts that favor
renting people have seen that buying a
home isn't a surefire way to create
wealth and they value flexibility on the
other hand mortgage availability is a
big driver of housing and so we've seen
that gotten certainly tight over the
past four or five years it may loosen up
a little bit but ultimately that's going
to drive housing recoveries in the
future I think the economy is is tepid
it's been ok for our business but until
you see income growth unemployment get
better you're not going to see that the
housing market come back strongly and we
kind of used to look at how's the
housing market doing as a barometer of
how the economy is doing if we're seeing
a structural shift into renting versus
owning does that change the way that
economists and sort of the stock market
needs to look at what the housing market
means like is it more how much people
are willing to pay in rentals is it
where people are renting that's more
significant in your view I think it's
shifted a little bit I mean certainly
the construction component in the GDP
growth component does Drive GDP and
that's been fairly weak you look at new
home building and it's nowhere near
historical averages but it is getting
better and I'd say until we see existing
home prices continue to rise and get
closer to what we look at which is
called replacement cost and what
builders
spend to build new homes you're really
not going to see construction really go
forward and pick up GDP do you own a
rent I own he opens look at better